atrás a las imágenes de los puntos d
efe que resultan de una potencia
concentró en el origen y razón de
potencia un medio así que un modo de
pensar en esta materia es que como el
centro es el origen lo que va a pasar es
que todos los puntos se van a ir a un
punto que esté en la misma dirección
pero a la mitad de la distancia así que
por ejemplo comenzamos con el punto d el
punto d tiene coordenadas menos ocho
coma menos nueve así que si está en
menos ocho va a pasar a tener coordenada
menos cuatro porque se va a acercar a la
mitad de la distancia original al origen
y en la coordenada ya estaba en menos
nueve así que va a pasar a menos 4.5
menos 4.5 así que el punto d se
transformaría en este punto de aquí qué
pasa con el punto y el punto tiene
coordenadas x igualados así que se va a
mover a un punto con coordenada x 1
y después tiene coordenada ye igual a 7
así que pasaría un punto con coordenadas
3.5
y ahí sería el punto y ahora el punto f
tiene coordenadas x igual a 6 y
coordenadas igual a menos 6 así que en
la coordenada x se acerca a la mitad de
la distancia ahora estaría en 3 y en la
coordenada ye pasaría a estar en menos 3
si conectamos loops y conectamos estos
tres puntos obtendríamos la imagen del
triángulo de efe bajo lado motes ya
concentro en el origen y razón un medio
contestemos las preguntas el punto d se
va al punto se transforma en el punto
pues el punto d tenía coordenadas menos
8 como a menos 9 y su imagen va a tener
coordenadas menos 4 coma menos 4.5 menos
cuatro coma menos 4.5 el punto y se
transforma en el punto con coordenadas
el punto estaba en 27 y se transforma en
el punto con coordenadas 13.51 3.5 y el
punto f se transforma en el punto pues
efe tenía coordenadas 6 menos 6 y su
imagen tiene coordenadas 3 coma menos 3
así que lo importante aquí es que como
el centro está en el origen como el
centro está en el origen
entonces los puntos esencialmente se
acercan a la mitad de la distancia de la
que estaban del origen sus coordenadas
se escalan por un factor de un medio
pero eso es cierto porque el centro es
el origen
estamos en lo correcto